arson is the recording in place
brilliant thanks very much martin okay
welcome everyone it's the meeting of the
cabinet of northeast derbyshire
district council
the date is the 27th of january it's 4
30.
with me in the chamber we have uh
councillor cupids
councillor powell
and councillor renick and i'm councillor
dale as well as officers we have matt
broughton a director
sarah sternberg as the monitoring
officer
jane dethick is a section 151 officer
and chris mills is our leisure
operations manager and i think on screen
we have council parking uh jill calling
him as a director
and alan marr from governance okay so
we'll get started with the meeting um
apologies for absence we've received
apologies from councillor kenyon who is
running late but he's hoping to be here
very shortly is stuck in in uh traffic
on the a61 i believe
uh and are there any others uh alan a
non-received chair okay lovely thank you
um declarations of interest from anyone
no okay
uh minutes the last meeting um
i'll move them as a true and accurate
record do we have a second
thanks councillor renick uh so all those
in favor
okay that's carried
and then we come to the first paper
which is the uh council plan targets
performance update
uh i'm not gonna dwell too much on this
paper it's there
uh in full detail within the within the
pack
um i think neither say we are making
good progress
uh towards a lot of our council fund
aims and ambitions despite uh the impact
of kobe which has obviously been
um pretty present in the past month or
so at least um certainly with the
omicron bavarian and various other
challenges we've had
um so yeah i think we're on track
clearly there are
um
some uh targets that we we're not
meeting and
they'll continue to be reviewed by
portfolio holders uh and raised
appropriately with uh with officers as
record as required so i don't think
there's anything else unless anyone else
wants to highlight any any other points
on that paper
if not i'll move that we
uh i'll move the recommendations which i
think are that we note it
should go back to the
yeah we um
we know there are note the quarterly out
turns
uh we mark eco04
has achieved uh within the kpis
and that mark we mark eco 09 16 and 21
as achieved
and their respective
strategy action plans be monitored more
fully through a suite of kpis and
service plan targets so i'll happily
move those recommendations do we have a
secondary
cancer cupid all those in favor
okay thank you that's carried and then
the next report i'll get back to the
agenda is the medium-term financial plan
so i'm going to hand over to councillor
parking first just to introduce us
thank you very much chair and apologies
for not being able to be with you today
but uh happy happy to be presenting this
paper
so today i'm presenting the mtfp for the
current year's budget which we approved
in november
the original budget for 2223
and the planning budgets for the
following three years were stretching
right out to 25 26.
so and the current year's budget remains
largely unchanged not surprising since
it was november that we passed it and
and since it was approved we we're not
anticipating any material changes at
this time
uh covet is still having an impact in
these budgets but much less than last
year
and some services are still recovering
from loss of income compared to
pre-pandemic levels but it's pleasing to
note
that they continue to improve
the covered assistance grant that we
received last year will be utilized to
meet cost pressures and lost income so
there isn't really any additional
pressure on the budget at this time
you'll be glad to hear
the national settlement was announced on
the 20th of december
and we
um actually were very pleasantly
surprised by the outcome
um the new homes bonus which
we widely was widely speculated not to
be in this settlement uh turned out to
be uh in there and helped us enormously
so
uh
because of our considerable growth in
new homes last year we received a
one-off payment okay
for of 609 000 pounds
uh in addition to that the lower tier
services grant has been paid again in 22
23
so uh again this is for one year only
and our allocation is 126
000 pounds
and finally there is a new one-off
services grant in 2022 to 2023
based on the existing settlement funding
assessment and our reward from this is a
hundred and ninety three thousand pounds
and now
these
these one one year uh settlements are
all well and good and we keep pushing
them back year by year by year but
ultimately the government
plans to consult over the next year on
updating the funding system and um
and have for the first time confirmed
that there will be transitional
protections when we eventually get the
new uh settlements
so to and that's to accompany any
funding reforms and kind of to soften
the blow
so it's important to us
and a lot of councils around the country
and it will give us a chance to um
adjust
our uh
our own funding plans
and there appears to be a genuine
attempt at leveling up in this
settlement uh leveling up between
councils of course not necessarily
anywhere else but leveling up between
councils uh in this settlement in that
it gives us some hope that in the
upcoming review um this approach will be
continued
um but we i guess we still have to wait
for the outcome of that review
it is also important to note that the
settlement information clearly states
that the additional funding is one-off
i'm emphasizing it for a reason uh so
whilst we are in a better position for
2022-23
we've effectively just moved that
funding
uh gap on one more year which is which
is good for us but we need to a little
bit more certainty when we get a chance
so in summary
the additional funding from the
settlement of
927 000 has been built into the
2022 budget
allowing us to set a balanced budget
okay a nice and another balanced budget
should i say
so um
forecasting for 2023 onwards
uh remains challenging because we don't
know the outcome of any settlement or
transitional funding
and
until we know about those it's very
difficult for us to uh to make accurate
predictions about what's going to happen
in the future
and so as usual we've used the
best possible information we have and
assumptions uh and uh
and we'll review them as soon as we know
anything different
so on to the budget
um
you'll be glad to know that i don't plan
to go through every number on in in
every table however uh i will draw your
attention to table one which is on page
47 of your packs should you wish to uh
have a look at that
uh and that summarizes the position
for next year assuming that the
council tax increases as recommended
bails are approved by council
then the budget is balanced without any
need for additional efficiencies however
as i said earlier the additional
settlement funding is a one-off which
means
that we need to maintain the momentum
that we've already got going
to make sure we reap the benefits of
those ongoing efficiencies um because
these are going to become more and more
important in
23 24 24 25.
um
so in terms of reserves
uh sorry as
efficiencies uh an efficiency plan has
been included with the ntfp
to provide additional information on how
budget gaps in future years will be met
this is in appendix 3 if you want to
take a look at that
and progress against the plan will be
monitored through the budget monitoring
process
in terms of reserves um
[Music]
these remain at acceptable levels the
resilience reserve will continue to
provide
resilience against budget gaps or
unforeseen expenditure in the future and
the
invest to save reserve remains at a
healthy level and we will con will
continue
to be utilized for spend to save
initiatives
the council tax this year we are
recommending to council
uh a five pound increase this year
there are no major changes to reporting
the hra
we are recommending to council that
rents increase in live with government
guidance and this is
something that this council has
has always followed
and so 4.1 this year
the rhl management fee has been
renegotiated in line with the
requirements of the new agreement
thank you council of powell
and others
uh will be and that will be 9.75 million
for the next year
and the general fund capital program
uh is
relatively static at the moment
the current capital program includes
additional budgets for further
modernization works on our non-tread
non-traditional stock
uh
and
i think
that's me uh are there any questions or
comments about uh about this mtfp
paper
thanks very much uh council uh parking
are there any uh comments or questions
from the topics
no anything you'd like to add uh jane
no thank you chair council parking
presentative very well thank you okay
anything else cancer parking before we
move on
no i'm uh i'm comfortable with uh with
the information we provided cabinet
today
brilliant thanks very much okay i'll
i'll happily move uh the recommendations
within the report obviously uh i wish to
thank kevin parkland and jane
and all of the team for all of their
work a huge amount of work going into
this every year
uh and you know it's a year-round
job i fully appreciate as well
um
i think the amount of work that we've
done uh to
as a whole organization actually to
um
detail some of those savings targets and
efficiencies over the coming years has
been really impressive and actually i'm
always reminded that when we
uh took office
uh we were reminded by our opposition of
uh of a significant deficit in future
years and
the paper before us is really clear
around how much work's gone into
to addressing that clearly that you know
times will still be
a challenge moving forward but but
actually we've got a clear plan
to deal with those challenges and and
you know
balanced budgets for the years to come
so i think that's really
you know it's testament to how much work
has gone into it and and impressive and
you know very much uh shows what
we as an administration can achieve
um the other thing i just just add is
that clearly with council tax
it's always a very very difficult
decision for any administration to make
we've always got to balance our own
needs as an organization with
you know our our residents
back pockets and clearly at the moment
it's a difficult challenging period with
the cost of living
so we do not take that decision lightly
but we also have to appreciate that we
as an organization are facing the same
sorts of challenges and and i think that
the
2.58 increases
uh you know although not insignificant i
think it's modest in the in the grand
scheme of things
and we do need it to be able to
balance our our budget moving forward
and continue delivering excellent
services for our residents so i do think
it's necessary um but that said clearly
you know sympathies with residents who i
know are
struggling as well themselves at the
moment
um i don't think there's anything else
i'm going to say but but other than move
the paper
is there a second thank you councillor
powell uh all those in favor
okay thank you very much that's uh
that's approved um
the next item's urgent items i don't
think there are any that i wish to raise
but i do just have a query about
the parking strategy on the top of the
paper it's labeled as as public but on
the agenda it's
um within the private session i just
wanted to query whether yes chair
the explanation for that is that the
paper doesn't include the exempt
information that was originally expected
so as a consequence uh with your
agreement it will be taken as a public
item and that the movement of public
exclusion of public will take place
after this paper is being dealt with
thank you so we'll move to item
eight on the agenda which is the parking
strategy which we'll do now in public as
you sail and then we'll exclude the
public thereafter so okay i'll hand over
to uh councillor powell uh who's gonna
talk to us about this paper um thank you
chair and as we all recall uh some time
ago one of our scrutiny committees
looked at parking
and came up with a number of ideas um we
felt then that
um the council needed a more
comprehensive parking strategy
um
as most of you know um a lot of our
estates are of non-traditional
house types built shortly after the war
when when car ownership was
if not zero but very slight
um of course all these years later we're
in a very much of a different world
where people have won two or even more
cars
and uh some of our estate roads are
having great difficulty coping with it
it's a big task however because very
little has been done over the
intervening years
so we decided we would develop a
strategy that we would
use over a number of years
we would devote
an amount in the budget per year
um and that we would set a criteria for
where our priorities should be
as a result of that um and other pilot
projects
um we we are now coming forward to
recommend a number of a number of our
objectives
and we're also looking at um another
method of surfacing
car parking spaces
uh
usually known as grass creed although
other types are available
um and uh we're going to um we're going
to uh pilot that in addlington avenue at
window with
that will be paid for by the residual
amount of the budget of 288 000 per year
that we've set
which comes from the um the housing
revenue account
um so we've got five uh projects to look
at um the strategy includes the criteria
so we're absolutely transparent about
where we go and what we do and how we do
it
um and on that basis chair i would uh
move the recommendations
thank you very much uh council powell do
we have a second bit uh council cupid
yeah thank you chair happy to second
that and um
completely echo council powell's
comments i think and just thanks to
officers and members i think as
everybody knows car parking some of the
problems is something i've been very
passionate about looking towards jill at
this point
and particularly the problems that
residents face that i think all of us as
elective members have sort of dealt with
and so i'm very grateful to the working
group for the work that we've done to
try and come up with a you know start
and this is just a start i know there
will be residents who'll say you know
what about my area and so it is a start
to try and start to work through it
because there are hundreds of sites
throughout the district but hopefully
these schemes will provide us with a
good kickstart and then opportunities
and other methods to be able to carry
that on in future years
brilliant um yeah absolutely agree and
thank cancer parking and and sorry
that's the power rather and cancer keep
it for all of their work on it as well
because i know that they've uh there's
been several working group meetings to
try and drive this forward and fully
agree i think there's anywhere in the
district that doesn't have some
challenges with parking
um you know we hear about it as elected
members a heck of a lot and i think
we're i'm really pleased that as an
administration we're bringing forward
potential solutions and it won't be done
overnight clearly we've got lots of
different areas and lots of potential
areas where we can help
but i think you know by starting by
committing that important funding on an
annual basis to deal with some of these
issues i think we will
gradually over time chip away at them
and hopefully improve
uh you know a real bug bear for
residents in the long term so
well done to
everyone who's been involved and thank
you very much for the the report uh i'll
move to the vote then uh all those in
favor
okay that's carried thank you very much
uh and then we'll move back to item
seven which is the exclusion of the of
the public and i therefore move that the
public be excluded from the meeting
during the discussion of the following
items of business to avoid the
disclosure to them of exempt information
as defined in part one of schedule 12a
the local government act
1972. um do we have a second
for cupid all those in favor
okay that's carried if we just have it
confirmed that the
feed has stopped
you